jensachi was asked about the federal
judge who blocked joe biden's vaccine
requirement for federal contractors and
here's what she said i don't have any
reaction to a federal judge in georgia's
decision to block the administration
from
enforcing the uh 2019 mandate vaccine
mandate for employees or
federal contractors
well the reason that we proposed these
uh these requirements is that we know
they work
and we are confident in our ability
legally to make these happen across the
country
as you know the federal government the
largest employer in the country we have
successfully implemented these
requirements in a way that have not only
boosted vaccinations in the federal
government with more than 90
percent of people vaccinated but also
helps avoid disruptions and operations
and our implementation sends a clear
messages to businesses including federal
contractors that similar measures will
protect their workforce protect their
customers and protect our communities
i'd also note that a number of
businesses across the country have also
implemented these requirements
vaccinating or testing requirements
depending on the organization and the
ceo of lockheed said last week that
there are at
uh they are at over 95 on track to be
compliant and are well on their way to
be able to maintain operations so i
would just note of course uh the
department of justice will vigorously
defend uh this in court but we know it
works that's why the president and the
administration will continue pressing
forward
man i don't like that chick i mean first
off we know it works well what she's
saying is we know that if we force you
to do something most people fall in line
just because you think you have the
power to do it and because a lot of
people are sheep doesn't mean it's good
it also depends what you mean by works
meaning it works that you force people
to get vaccinations that they need
another vaccination and another booster
and now omicron is coming and unicron
and again and again and again and again
so it works is a bit of a
you're being a little sloppy there uh
but the line really we are confident in
our ability legally to make these
happen across the country
no lady a federal judge just said no
she's saying we're confident in our
ability legally no the federal judge you
know
saki if you're watching i don't know if
you know this what you do as a press
secretary is you lie right so the
administration comes in they tell you
can you message our [ __ ] and we want
to force people to do things that are
unconstitutional because we do have a
right to privacy you have a right to
choice right okay we these are things
we've had in america for a long time but
joe or who's ever pulling joe's puppet
strings says saki you got to tell people
that we're doing this thing so they come
in with this ridiculous mandate right
she says it's illegal the judge then
says and judges are the ones who decide
what's legal judges they do this crazy
thing they get a lot of papers in front
of them it's nuts i've got papers here
too they get papers and they look at
what the law says and then they analyze
the law and then they debate it with
other judges and then it goes through
the courts and we have lower level
courts and we have circuit courts and
sometimes jen things move all the way up
to the supreme court and those are the
ultimate deciders of what is legal or
not you you soulless freak are not a
legal expert so just because you say
it's legal well a judge a federal judge
just said it ain't and people are sick
of your [ __ ] and i think we are
getting to a tipping point i think
people have had it with these people i i
talked to a lot of people yesterday and
i know what who i talk to may be
somewhat self-selecting and all of that
but
i think people are sick of the mandates
altogether even the people who were
going along with it the entire time are
now going wait a minute wait a minute i
did i did my uh shot i did my second
shot i did my booster now fouchy and the
rest of them are saying oh this doesn't
even count as fully vaccinated and why
isn't the country fully open and why am
i still showing a passport and why do
they still want me wearing a mask
so you know what fouchy you know what
sake you know what biden keep pushing
keep pushing at this point keep going
keep going keep going because we've got
midterms coming and i think you guys are
in for a wake-up call that is going to
be rather extraordinary